[Music]
hello and thank you very much indeed to
everyone who's tuned in uh to this talk
i should let you know that i am not
speaking as an mp let alone as a
government minister i'm speaking as
someone who's interested in ideas have
training in philosophy
taught the subject at one point and is
keen to think about where these
important concepts came from and what
they mean and whether we can think about
them productively for the future so uh
the talk is the virtues of commerce and
let's crack on in the first
slide and just start i think by pausing
for a moment to ask ourselves
where we are now in particular because a
global pandemic has swept uh across
uh countries and continents
uh and has brought us all into i think a
a new sense of the fragility of our own
lives perhaps or our society our nations
and perhaps our interrelationships with
each other personal and national so
kovid
forces us to think about what it is we
care about what it is we cherish and
what we wish for the future and that's
an incredibly important thing i've
called it a coveted revolution because
of course some people many people
and in particular many people from the
left of politics and of uh political
thinking and i have in mind people like
judith butler or in this country perhaps
amir sunivasan or in america katrina
forrester have thought about
this as potentially a moment where
we could take stock and
potentially
there might be in due course because for
a revolution that overturned uh the
values that they take to be
intrinsic or some of them take to be
intrinsic to our current way of life and
and of course if you think that uh
contemporary society is is um
preoccupied with and only a matter of
inequality or domination of
class on class or a certain kind of uh
elite hubris then of course that
revolution is going to be incredibly
welcoming and of course
there are elements of all of these
things and you don't have to look far to
see them
but i'm going to argue that actually
commerce and
what can be called commercial society
have virtues and values of their own and
we need to reflect on those before we
think about revolutionary change that we
might want to impose on them
now if we think about society uh a
simple classification that would be
widespread might be a distinction into
agrarian or industrial societies uh a
distinction perhaps between uh
capitalist and uh communist societies
but of course there is seems to be a
kind of
fixed expectation in uh many people's
minds and perhaps in many countries that
the future in one form or another is
about some form of capitalism now i'm
not sure that's true
at all and for reasons that we'll come
to i'm not sure that's really what we
should be thinking about particularly
but it's worth just noting that there
are different varieties of capitalism
available around the world there are
what you might call countries with
western style
liberal democratic capitalism uh there
is china which combines communist
politics with
capitalist economics
there are countries that are based on
economies that are dominated by the
armed forces or in some cases by
particular interests might be drugs in
some cases in the past uh historically
or in some cases perhaps today
or it might be other forces that shape
the nature of the capitalism that they
have so even capitalism itself is not a
settled uh or unitary category and i
think it's important to note that up
front and of course how countries
achieve whatever state of development
they have may itself be wildly different
one from another there may be countries
that have come together as germany did
out of dutchies and principals in the
19th century uh there may be countries
that have
achieved or enjoyed a fairly stable
unitary political status as this country
has of course with disagreements over
the years since uh the early 17th
century
or the early 18th century depending on
how you think of it and of course there
are a host of different uh options and
different possibilities in between there
will be countries that have been uh and
still bear the legacy positive or
negative of colonialism of empire and
many other different pathways to the
current state that they have and these
things interplay with each other one
thing however that does seem to be
characteristic
of our current era is not just the
assumption that somehow capitalism
perhaps following the fall of the berlin
wall in 1989 is some form of
inevitability but also that the way to
think about these things is through
the lens of economics economics is the
mechanism by which we should
evaluate
the strength or well-being of given
societies and it's economics it should
be the
principle guiding tool when we come to
make trade-offs between uh people uh or
interests uh within countries and across
countries over time so that really is a
way of just setting the scene for
uh the argument that i want to make
uh now i want to start with a great hero
of mine i've written a book about him uh
adam smith uh of course not necessarily
familiar to everyone in his own uh in
his own full being um i think everyone
would think of him many people think of
him as the
father of
economics and
in the sense that economics comes of age
with the placing of markets
at the center uh of that body of thought
then i think that's an appropriate
description i mean there there is
economics plenty of economics before
smith
wrote the wealth of nations but all
economics afterwards bears its stamp in
different forms and it does so because
it is so emphatically focused on uh the
functioning of markets and the benefits
and of course the drawbacks
of markets uh as part of a wider scheme
of an understanding of how societies and
how economies develop
and for smith the crucial change that he
had seen uh in british history in
scottish history and that was powering
its way through in his own lifetime was
the transition from what he took to be
feudalism into commercial society now
what was that
change
well for smith feudalism is marked by
personal dependency so you might have a
lord of the manor or a great aristocrat
or indeed ultimately the king or queen
and arising from that source of
authority and power and wealth there
would be a relationships of a personal
dependence uh working their way through
society and you have of course in the
16th century and afterwards this idea of
the great chain of being that somehow
people's function is defined by where
they sit in society and that's all they
can ever respond to and all they should
aspire to
and that somehow that is divinely
licensed and uh ratified now that view
is one that he takes adam smith takes to
have been decisively superseded
uh in the uh 17th and 18th centuries and
that is through the move towards or
towards what he calls commercial society
and a commercial society for him is he
has a lovely phrase description of it he
says it's a society essentially in which
um every man of course he's only talking
about men as was the time the practice
of the time every man is in himself as
it were a merchant and lives by
exchanging so it's a society of exchange
and it's a society in which people in
the act of exchanging uh treat each
other as presumptive equals they may not
in fact be equals economically or
in terms of the hierarchy or status or
the other ways you might think about it
but they cheat and treat each other for
the purposes of exchange presumptively
as equal and therefore uh he sees that
as a much more
equal and indeed equalizing uh set of
social arrangements than feudalism and
one that's not marked by personal
dependency you need have no direct
personal relationship with someone if
you're exchanging adam smith one point
points to his coat and speculates on the
innumerable trades that may have been
involved in producing the dye and the
wool that it's made from and of course
he need have no knowledge of the people
who did the dyeing or generated the dye
itself or did the carving or the combing
or the weaving of the coat
and he doesn't need to because
the action of markets through society is
what guarantees uh the availability of a
code to him and ultimately it's quality
so
a commercial society need not be one
that relies on personal relationships as
such uh or indeed personal dependency
so that's the broad picture and what is
so interesting about that of course is
that uh somehow this idea of exchange
has been preoccupied in people's minds
by economic exchange and of course that
is a central part of the wealth of
nations but of course that misses out
what you might call its moral
dimension and for smith all exchange has
a moral dimension and uh he wrote a book
before he wrote the wealth of nations
the theory of moral sentiments which
talks about how that moral dimension to
our lives how value how norms
are generated
in society and what he says is
extraordinarily interesting he says that
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas